Candid Truth. What is up everybody?
Thank you for joining us at Candid
Truth. We're going to talk about the
truth and we're going to get candid with
it tonight. I got a very special guest,
my friend Aaron Fron. I'm not going to
lie, we just met tonight, but I feel
like I know him
because he put out this book. He put out
this amazing documentary called Age of
Transitions. What up, Aaron Fran? So
good to Is it Fran or Fr?
Fron. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Name. Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. Great to be here, Mikey.
Thanks for having me. Yeah, man. Um, so
I remember seeing this documentary. I
kind of had my awakening. I definitely
did have my awakening. December 2011,
went down the rabbit hole, was up till
4:00 a.m. every day on Alex Jones and
all this stuff, you know, which now I
believe he's a double agent. But he did
put out the truth in a sense that
everything he said, he was like, "It's
declassified. It's right here. It's it's
it's admitted." You know, it's like, but
he would never go deeper. And that's
when I started having questions. But I
started going down that rabbit hole,
4:00 a.m. every night and stuff. and
somehow ran across your documentary,
which I thought was around that time.
But when did you put that out? What
year?
I first published The Age of Transitions
Online on Google Video in 2008.
2008. Okay. So, yeah. So, maybe I could
have seen it. I think it was kind of
around 2012,
2013 at the latest 2014 when I saw it.
But when I saw it, it was free, but I
was like, I gotta buy this. I gotta have
it on DVD, and it comes with this
awesome book. So, the book is called
Revolve. You can see the oraoris that we
often talk about on this channel. And um
can you explain like what's going on in
the green there?
Yeah. Uh well, that's uh William Blake
painting down there at the bottom of
Jacob's ladder. Yeah. So, uh, the angels
are ascending up and descending down
from heaven back to earth again. And
yes, the Orura Boris around that. That
was an image,
uh, created by the alchemist and artist
Jacob Bowam. So, I kind of amalgamated
the two of those for the cover of the
book. And yeah, the book it's still
available, still have Revolve out there.
And I I I published that I think first
in 2011 was when the book came out.
originally. Okay. And yeah, it's about
transhumanism as the age of transitions
film is. But I mean, half of the book I
have dedicated to the more occult and
esoteric side of transhumanism. So
that's a big part of the book and thus
the cover with the alchemical imagery in
it. Yeah, man. you were really you had
your finger on the pulse of this thing
because back then AI I mean we heard the
term artificial intelligence but about
the best it was was like a PlayStation
game or something. I mean, I don't
remember any artificial intelligence
that really impressed me like, whoa,
it's almost like it's human, but I
remember in the documentary talking
about things like um this guy, his dad
died and he really missed his dad and so
he was trying to bring his dad back to
life through transhumanism. He wanted to
capture his soul or his essence in a
digital format and that maybe it could
have been AI, which they're doing now.
If you guys haven't found out, read this
article. Um, I might be able to pull it
up
actually. The husband of gold of
um, what's that chick from thre's
company?
You're talking about um,
Suzanne Summers. Suzanne Summers. Yeah.
Suzanne Summers. Her her husband is
somehow into transhumanism. Is that it?
Yeah. So, check this out. Um, this is
the New York Post. Well, I don't know
how how far into it he is, but um when
the scene changes here, is it going to
change? So, what's going on here? Trying
to Here we
go. Switch, man. It's lagging.
I So this is the husband of Suzanne
Summers, you say? Yeah, look at all
these popups. Um, this is interesting.
So the the husband of Suzanne Summers,
it says Suzanne Summers husband
requested her AI twin hopes to make more
Thre's Company episodes using it. She
would endorse it. She She died not too
long ago. Um Oh, she did. So she is
already deceased. I didn't know that. I
don't remember that happening. Yeah, her
shocking death in October 2023. And it
says, "Meeting you was like a breath of
fresh air," the replica told Harnell 88
in a video. Oh my god. Yeah, it's hard
for me to like find the the best article
on it, but basically Suzanne Summer's AI
robot reunites with
Allen. I mean, so this is getting into
like digital spiritualism. I mean, we're
we are coming to a really strange time
when we're bringing back the dead
through AI. It's like it's like
technology meets necromancy, which I
think is kind of um like alchemy, right?
Yes. It's there's just so many
questions. I'm you got me thinking about
that article now because I I know for a
fact that James Earl Jones before he
died, he signed
over to his estate um you know his
family, he signed in his will, it was a
big thing, the rights to reproduce his
voice via AI technology so that they can
make more material using his synthetic
voice. But he had to sign off on that.
So I'm wondering like I'm getting into
the weird legal side of Suzanne Summers
and her husband. And I would like to
read that article now because I wonder
if she similarly signed off on saying,
"Yeah, you can uh keep making AI
versions of me and my husband can keep
making money off of me after I'm dead,
you But I I that gets into like all
these weird legal issues for one thing,
but yes, spiritual
and definitely spiritual territory and
and odd. This is the world we live in,
the world of deep
fakes, but uh not just deep fakes, but
do you call it a deep fake when you know
it's just uh when you know that it's an
AI to begin with? So you just keep
making movies with people who are dead
deceased. We got new Marlin Brando
movies coming out or something. We know
that it's not actually him. So this
opens up all
these strange questions for sure. Yeah.
And and yeah, if you just use them as
like a a puppet or something or like a
deep fake like you're
saying, I could kind of see that. But
what if AI what if movies are just all
AI? AI writes the script. AI is doing
the acting. AI is doing the
cinematography. Like we're we are really
getting into some weird stuff. So, I
truly believe and and we we talked
before the show. Uh this channel's a
Christian channel. Aaron's not a
Christian, so we might believe a little
differently on this stuff. I believe
Satan wants to give the world a
counterfeit heaven, basically. And
so imagine if you're offering the world
VR goggles or Google glasses or whatever
and you're using AI and you're speaking
things into existence. You are God. You
speak, it happens. You go into this
black world. You don't have to work
anymore because AI's taken over every
job. I mean Elon Musk has already said
this that AI is going to take over so
many jobs that we need some kind of like
universal allowance system basically
which I think will be the social credit
score. You're based on are you a good
citizen and what makes you a good
citizen is dictated by the elites of the
world. And so if your credit score goes
down, you don't get to ride the bus. you
don't get to, you know, get take your um
your gray Tesla or whatever that
everybody has and you don't. So, you're
in a world where you put on these
goggles and you just say, "I want to be
at the beach. I want to be sunset. I
want uh Angelina Jolie out here." You
know, whatever you say, it happens. And
in that world, there's no rules. It's
every every person's sickest fantasies.
and they'll justify it by saying, you
know what, at least they're not hurting
people in the real world. So now
minority attracted persons or people who
have like, I don't know, thoughts of
killing people or whatever, um, dmer and
all those people, they can act those
things out in that world and not hurt
anyone. But your brain doesn't know the
difference in virtual reality and real
reality. Like they've done these CT
scans and tests and stuff that show when
you look at silly faces and you do the
faces well, your brain fires off a
certain way, but when you go back inside
that same MRI machine and you do not
move a muscle, your brain still fires
off as if you're doing it. So, I don't
know if you've looked into some of
stuff, but we've um Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I
mean so much of what you said pops in a
lot of ideas. Uh there at the beginning
you were kind of touching on the
concept the truly religious concept of
creation. Yeah. Right.
And there's various myths throughout
time that kind of reference this
one similar idea
uh of God's creative power really is
what it's about. There's the lost word.
It's referred to a lot of times like the
lost word. I know that Manley Ph. Hall
had a book entitled The Lost Word of
Freemasonry. It references this. I think
the myth of Osiris and his uh I think
he's chopped up into 14 pieces if I
remember. And the missing piece is his
uh penis, right? Uh yeah, exactly.
That's the missing piece. But of course,
that's his regenerative uh symbolizing
his regenerative principle. So there's
this concept of this godly creative
power which is always implied to be
within us human beings.
that needs to
be reattained. It's like it was lost at
some point in the distant future.
Uh this is the myth and that we have to
work toward it with the Freemasons, it
would be the great work, right? And the
whole idea
is if you're talking the lost word, the
word God
speaks things into existence, right? God
speaks the creation to into existence.
This is in um the scriptures and all
that.
That's an interesting concept because
there's so much to like pull out of
that. It's the idea of like, well, okay,
this is what God is said to have done.
But what if literally we get to a space
where we speak or we think and as we
speak we create, right? And we like
literally create. And if you're in a
virtual world, that's how that works,
right? you like think and you create
what you want. So that's the techn
technological way of attaining that and
it's very a religious thing and for a
long time the people that were espousing
these technologies would like to pretend
like they're hardcore atheists and all
this stuff but there's very religious
aspect to all this. There always has
been. Yep. Usually it's gnosticism,
uh, luciferianism basically,
like you know those terms, right? Um,
Oh, yeah. Oh, yeah. Yeah. Gnosticism is
fascinating in and of itself. Yeah. Uh,
the Gnostics, uh, there's a few Gnostics
running around online over the past
decade or two. They make podcasts and
stuff. That's interesting to look up.
But they would claim to be the true
Christians. The Gnostics would. Right.
So, you know, which is really weird
though because when you really look into
the belief of it, they believe that the
the serpent in the garden or Sophia
was the one that was telling them that
God or Yaldabboth or who whatever his
name is exactly has created this perfect
garden prison for you. And he's he's
keeping you from that tree of knowledge.
He doesn't want you to have knowledge.
He doesn't want you to evolve into a
higher state of being. But I've come to
set you free and tell you the truth. And
if you eat that fruit, you'll become
like God. And this is the same. This
this idea has been propagated in so many
mainstream movies. The Matrix. Eat this
red pill or an apple. Your eyes will be
open. Morpheus is wearing a trench coat
made out of scales, not leather. And
he's saying if you eat it, your eyes
will be open. You'll know the truth. And
he takes him to a world with no rules.
You can bend the rules and sometimes
break them. Morpheus gets on or Neo gets
on the telephone at the end and he says,
"I'm going to he's talking to the
creator of the Matrix and he says, "I'm
going to expose you and I'm going to
show the people a world without you,
without rules, without boundaries and
where we go from here." You know, the
the possibilities are endless. Um Truman
Show, same thing. Perfect world. The guy
in the moon, Kristoff and Moses, they
when he got to the edge and was going to
walk out into utter darkness, he was
like, "No, don't go out there." like
there's there's nothing but pain out
there. Like I've created this perfect
world for you. Just stay here. And he
says, "Good morning, good evening, and
good night." And he walks out into utter
darkness. And everybody applauds. Yeah,
you'll see it when you know what to look
for. You'll see nasticism in so many
movies. Kids movies like Smallfoot, Lego
Movie. It's always about break the rules
and follow your heart or do what you
want to do. Yeah. The Gnostics believe
that the god of the world, the demiurge,
which I believe if I remember is their
Jehovah, Yeah. is a god that a god
that's controlling us and manipulating
us and one that is standing in the way
of us realizing our true selves, which
are spiritual. And there's a lot of
strange sex magic stuff actually within
Gnosticism that they uh the Gnostics are
an interesting group and uh they have
some pretty wild
ideas and as I was saying like their
podcast if you listen to their
podcasts the sorts of things that
they are espousing are just really it's
pretty wild in one sense. They're
they're almost
more conservative and reactionary in
terms of like uh they'll just rail
against things like lesbianism. They'll
say like it's the greatest evil ever and
they'll they'll one second they'll be
doing that and then the next second
they'll be uh telling you about how to
you know um some weird sex magic stuff.
They're very into the concept of kitis
reservatus where you're supposed to with
the male is supposed to withhold their
seed, right? And that's part of uh but
anyway that's I actually didn't know
that much about them on that level. Um
the Bible talks about the Gnostics for
for bidding marriage and eating
pleasurable foods and things like that.
So that's where you get things like nuns
and monks and all this stuff
that's in religion as well.
Man, we already started on a rabbit
trail. Yeah. Well, there's there's a lot
of cults out there. Uh and they're all
interesting to look at and uh a lot of
them do tie back to transhumanism. Yeah.
And certainly transh humanism I I feel
like at this point they're doing less to
hide the fact that they are a religion
in and of themselves. Anthony
Leandowski, that guy, Silicon Valley guy
that got himself in trouble for uh he he
was working for Google and then what he
essentially did was like get a bunch of
uh Google stuff and then take it over to
I believe it was Whimo where he was
working and he stole Google corporate
secrets and and took them over to there.
He got in trouble for that. Trump ended
up pardoning this guy after his first
term. But this this guy Leandowski, he
started up a
church where the god of the church is
this yet to be realized AGI artificial
intelligent god that that he and his
buddies are going to create. That's
their god that they need to create.
Yeah. I I forget what his church is
called, but uh he I think he made a
501c3 and all that. He was official
about it and uh Trump essentially sprung
him out of jail. I don't I haven't
looked into Leandowski recently. I don't
know what he's up to now, but you know,
that's just one example of uh the nuts
in Silicon Valley. Um the kind of stuff
that they do. And from time to time,
they'll tell you the truth in their
insane way. Yeah. Well, uh Trump's
supposed to save us from all this stuff,
though, right? I mean, he's he's the
guy, right?
Well, that's another example of at one
point he might have been pretending
that, but now he
really he it's it's all out on the table
what the Trump regime is all about. I
mean, it's been bought and paid for by
big tech. Those are the guys who
financed his entire campaign. A lot of
them are on in his cabinet now. Yeah. Uh
many of them are still working behind
the scenes. Um, so yeah, there's there's
a mess of them. I mean, Elon Musk is the
most prominent one, but you've got
Morgan
Drees, you've got Peter Teal, you've got
the who's the Cryptozar guy. His name
escapes me now, but he's another one of
them. Yeah, I can't remember.
Uh the the yeah the Trump show is
replete with these guys and and they
absolutely are using the presidency
to get get what they want. Yeah. I mean
it's
interesting when the Democrats were in
and the liberal left was going hard. The
Republicans are just like we want all
this stuff to change. Trump's going to
drain the swamp. He's going to get rid
of all this stuff. And literally like
his first week in or something, he's
rolling out AI Stargate, AI governance
where we're all, you know, it's big
brother like 1984 Brave New World. We're
all going to be surveillance 24/7 by not
by people, not by guys that are watching
monitors, but by AI gods. I mean, like
straight up Terminator Skynet stuff. And
this is the dude that's supposed to be
saving us. and his right-hand man is the
richest man in the world. So you, you
know, these QAnon people are all against
the elitist and all that, but you got
the richest man in the world as your
sidekick who wants to microchip
everyone's brains and bring out all the
drones, like all the robots. Like, come
on. Like, bring out the robots that are
AI
robots. They're you're not controlling
them with a controller. They're doing
what they want to do.
Yeah. Yeah. Crazy stuff. There's there's
a lot of angles to this, but I honestly
sometimes I wonder how much of this is
like a social experiment. Yeah, dude. Of
using online social media channels as
their workshop, their laboratory to see
honestly what we all will buy, what kind
of BS they can throw at us and we'll
just say yes to it because there's been
a whole lot. And this guy next to us is
prime example. A lot of people happily
voted him in thinking a lot of things,
projecting a lot of concepts onto him
that are false, quite frankly.
And the propaganda that was used to put
this buffoon in, yeah, was absolutely
uh exploiting
what do we call it? Alternative ideas,
conspiracy culture, uh concepts, uh
whatever the alternative I don't know if
you have a label for all this stuff,
Mikey. I I I struggle with it myself.
There used to be a thing called the
truth movement. You know what I mean?
But you know what I'm referring to?
Yeah. It's all muddied up now. Like that
that's how they do it. This the Hegelian
dialectic. Like they play both sides. So
you got the obvious like crazy insane
wicked people. Like you can be dogs, you
can be whatever. There there's gender's
fluid. Everything. And then you got the
truthers. But you have to get in there
and put out the disinformation, the
misinformation. You have to muddy up the
waters in the truther community as well.
So you got things like QAnon, which I
don't buy into at all. I mean, there's
there's elements of truth in all that
stuff. I do believe that there's
trafficking and all that kind of stuff
going on, but the whole QAnon, they they
have prophecies and all this kind of
stuff. Uh man, I wish I could remember
in the UFO movement and all that. I
don't know what you think about all
that, but I've been into aliens and UFOs
my whole life. uh until 2012 when I woke
up and I'm like, dude, this is all
uh this is all a giant deception that's
going to come. You you remember William
Cooper? He was doing the same thing. He
he was in the military seeing the UFOs
hit into the water, the water parts. I
mean, it's like defying physics and
everything. And he's like using his own
radio system like, "Man, these these
things are real." And then he's like,
"Wait a minute. They lured me right into
their trap. They wanted me to expose
this and make it like they wanted to use
him as a leaker, as a whistleblower, but
in reality, it was a big plan to bring
about new world order, fake alien
invasion. I believe it'll be spiritual.
I believe it's demonic. And we're
already to the point now with 2025 where
they're saying, "Oh, there's all kinds
of things flying in our skies. We don't
know what they are." But it's okay. Keep
shopping. And they're getting us used to
the idea of things being in our skies.
It's the frog in the the boiling pot,
you know, just turn up the heat of Oh,
yeah. Remember those things? Yeah,
they've been around for a while. They
haven't hurt us or
anything. But I I believe that some big
things are right around the corner that
we are just not even ready for. And the
whole reason I bring that up is
because I believe that the the truther
community is being the waters are being
muddied in there and so now we just
don't even know what to believe anymore.
Right. The the the thing about there's
so much going on with the truther
community. Uh because the average person
has quite frankly been programmed to
write them off. It's just a bunch of
cooks. They're who cares what they who
cares what they Yeah. Who cares what
they've ever? Who cares what they're
thinking now? When in reality, I would
say that the average person would do
well to try to understand what the
alternative conspiracy world is, what it
has been doing, uh where it has brought
us, because it absolutely has everything
to do with the inception of this regime.
Again, the Trump, it's a Trump regime,
okay? And it
absolutely was sold on the ideas all the
same ideas that anybody who has been in
that world knows about the and in fact
uh much to the chagrin of you know what
we're supposed to believe I would say
the average person is very much in line
with a good amount of conspiracy
uh worldview. Yeah. if that's what we're
supposed to call it. Most people are
just generally in line with that. And I
think the proof is in the pudding.
That's why once again, this guy is here
because they knew uh for one thing all
of the truth media was digital. It was
online. It was a workshop for the people
behind these campaigns. Once again,
social experiment online laboratory.
Yeah. Uh, you have data and analytics
for your show, right, Mikey?
Yeah.
Do do you think that these guys who own
these entire social media systems don't
have Oh, yeah. detailed analytics on
things. Yeah. They see Joe Rogan and all
that stuff and they like, okay, yeah,
millions of views on here. Gotcha.
Mhm. So, what I'm trying to say is that
uh there's a reason that all of these
formerly alternative ideas now they're
essentially just mainstream were used to
get us where we are now. Yeah. I think
like one in four of the young
generation, I don't know if they're X or
Z or whatever, but believe the Earth's
flat. I mean, that's a pretty big
number. One in four or something like
that. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah, it's and and it's it's a real
shame because there's stuff like that
that is just like obviously ridiculous
and and and and if there is an
experiment to see what we will believe,
that's definitely one of them. They
fooled me stuff like that. Well, I Okay.
Well, I'm I I don't mean to like No, no,
you're good, man. Dude, that is a that
is such a Yeah. fringy topic, but I've
looked into it a lot. Yeah. Yeah. It's
okay. And and look, Mikey, I'm not here
to like mock anybody. And even if I'm
Listen, I've been doing this for so long
that I I have I have a I see this as a
personal investment that I've made, I've
continued to make. And I get I'm at the
point where I get um emotional about
things where I didn't used to. And I
don't anybody who's been fooled by any
of this I am not mad about. Even though
I will get mad when I talk about these
things because I know um you know the
people perpetrating this I know what
they're about. But the victims of this
uh
I not just empathize with but I would
say I am one too because I certainly
have been fooled along the way and I've
grown and I see the kind of crap that
they do now and I've I've had enough for
one thing. But I'm not stopping
because it's so easy to just like throw
your hands up in the air and say, "Oh,
this is just a bunch of garbage. I'm
done."
And I don't see many people making that
connection that I was talking about
before. Like look, this is it. Like if
you want to understand what's going on
in America, like how we're coming to the
edge of this cliff that we all know that
we're standing on now. We all know that,
right? That's just obvious. It's
obvious. Like you you it's just there.
That's how everything's coming out.
Diddy Files, Epstein, Nickelodeon, like
everything's coming out now. So people
are brought to a state of hopelessness.
That's why I believe it's the whole
order out of chaos. I think all that
stuff coming out is
purposeful honestly.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Exactly. It wouldn't
be coming out if it wasn't supposed to.
Right. Right. There's no such thing as
whistle. I say this all the time.
There's no such thing as a whistleblower
on mainstream media news. So when News
Nation has some guy from the military
saying, "Yeah, there's a 20 foot
eggshaped craft and I picked it up with
a helicopter and all this stuff like
you're not a whistleblower, dude. Like
you're on you're not Snowden." Like I
actually put more Credence into Snowden
who's running for his life than the
supposed whistleblower on Fox News, you
know?
Yeah.
Yeah. There's a lot going on, but again
with just the exploitation of this
material, if
you going back to Mark Andre, one of the
guys who essentially bought this uh
Trump administration and is uh using it
to his advantage. Um if you
read his techno, what is it? Techno
optimist manifesto I believe is the
title of this crazy thing. I believe he
p published it last year. Um I read
through it. It's pretty quick. Thank god
he doesn't go on for very long. But if
you read it to me when I read that
thing, it sounded like every uh it was
just replete with all these like
online alternative specifically
libertarian concepts that I've heard
throughout this conspiracy culture
ecosystem. I again, I've been doing this
for so long. I'm like, he just sounds
like another guy
that has that's a guest on a radio show.
And wouldn't you know it, he's been a
guest on Joe Rogan. Now, all these guys
have become guests as of late on Joe
Rogan. Peter Theal has been a guest on
Joe Rogan. Andre's been a guest on Joe
Rogan. I think some of these Oh,
Zuckerberg's been a guest on Joe Rogan.
Wow, that's true. True.
What do you think that's all about? But
Zuck went cool, man. He got the necklace
and the haircut. Like he remember he
said, "Um, we we used to censor you, but
now we're not going to anymore." Even
though we told you that we're not
censoring you. That was the funny part
right there.
They they denied the censorship, but now
they're going to take away the
censorship that they didn't do. Mhm. Oh,
yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. So I mean they
know in one sense they know what ways
the wind is blowing. So they want to uh
buy influence which they have but
there's much more than that going on and
uh
it's I'm just sick of pe seeing people
fall for this. It's it's got to stop.
These guys are not looking out for our
best interest. Yeah. Uh there's the
other aspect of the story with these
tech guys that it's been my contention.
I've been covering this on my show, The
Age of Transitions, for years now. Yeah,
definitely check out Aaron's podcast,
Age of
Transitions. Also, the name of his cool
documentary that you can't find on
YouTube. Maybe you'll find a mirror of
it, but he's got on the website. What's
your website? Yep. Yeah, the age
ofts.com. you'll uh I have the link or I
have the video on there if you want to
watch the original Age of Transitions
video. There's my podcast there and the
podcast I got in the background there is
available on uh I guess Amazon or on
your website. Well well again just go to
the age of transitions.com you can find
the link to the book there and yeah
don't don't go to
Amazon go straight to the source.
Yeah. Yeah. So, thank you for that,
Mikey. But, um, but yeah, uh, it's
my contention that big tech has been in
this, uh,
yearslong takeover, so to speak, of the
military-industrial complex. And that's
not to say that they haven't been actors
within that world for quite some time
anyway. Um, but I feel like there
actually is this
um antagonism between big tech and the
old aerospace industries that dominated
the old military-industrial complex as
we know it. You know, Northrup Grumman,
Rathon, Boeing, all those guys. Oh yeah.
I do believe that big tech is making a
move to usurp them and put themselves in
place. And you you see that through
efforts of guys like Eric Schmidt, the
former head of Alphabet Google. He's
been all over the place working with the
Pentagon and he's been on all the
billion different AI committees advising
the government and the Pentagon. I'm
like, yeah, the future war is going to
be technological. We have to develop AI.
If we don't, China's going to get us. Uh
so all those talking points from from
him and from big tech and from them
wanting to be the new
military-industrial complex getting all
this government contracts for the new
weapons, the new wars. All of that you
can see in this new regime as well. The
Trump regime absolutely
um is is is doing this too. So yeah,
let's uh let's check out this clip. And
so I actually used AI, ironically, you
know, AI is ultimately going to be our
demise. Like we opened up Pandora's box
and like you said, if we don't do it,
somebody else is going to do it. So
we're kind of like we have to now. But
it's fun. It's convenient. All that kind
of stuff, but I'd rather live without
it, honestly, um because I know where
it's headed. But I used AI to um kind of
get a synopsis in your book about this
about this stuff that's going on. And
they're following this stuff out like a
playbook. So here's a short clip from
Trump
here. It's supposed to be. Hello. Why is
it not
playing? Oh my. Okay. What was supposed
to happen in this clip?
I saw something about the golden age and
Saturn. I like all that. Okay. So, yeah,
he's he's basically he's saying the
golden age. That's all he's saying in
there. I have a clip of him talking
about the golden age. And so, this
synopsis of u part of your book anyway,
or part of the
um yeah, the the outline of it is
Saturn's role in the golden age myth.
So, why why are we keep talking about
this golden age? What is this all about
and what all is wrapped up in it? So, we
know Saturn, golden age myth and Roman
mythology, Saturn ruled over the golden
age, a time of peace and abundance
before the fall of man. I think that's
interesting. Before the fall of man.
Occult groups often see this age as a
time to return to. So like the occult
wants to return back to this golden age
of uh
abundance. But rather than repentance
and submission to God, it is achieved
through secret knowledge, that tree of
knowledge of good and evil, merging man
with machine or activating hidden divine
potential. So evolving yourself u
reaching that higher state of
consciousness.
Um you Fron critiques this showing how
the elite are reviving Saturn Saturnian
worship under the guise of a utopian
scientific future when in fact it is a
veiled system of control and
destruction. So these are the points to
look at. Saturn or the first the golden
age that's ruled by Saturn a promise of
peace merging man with machine secret
knowledge evolving through by divine
potential and it's ultimately going to
be this
dystopian control system.
So we see right here where he says the
golden age of America that Trump is the
one saying this. He's the guy that
everybody's putting all their trust in.
Yet he's using this terminology and the
occultists have been predicting that
2025 is going to be this uh
externalization of the hierarchy which
means literal demonic manifestations in
our world. Alice Bailey and uh Blovatsky
and all them and that it's the age of
Aquarius coming. That's what this whole
shift is. Um they're predicting that
2025 would be that. And now here's this
leader who's saying that we're going to
enter the golden
age. And when he got
inaugurated, I guess that's the right
word. I'm so like non-political. when
when he took his like
oath. This is supposed to happen
outside. Notice he's inside of a
building. All the other presidents did
it outside. It happened like once inside
another time. Um, and this is the apo
This is the apotheiois of Washington.
Above his head is a painting of
Washington and it's titled the
apotheiois of Washington. That literally
means turning George Washington into a
god. I'm not I'm not just like spinning
that to to fit my narrative. That's what
it means. And notice what his wife is
wearing. This strange hat that's
covering most of her head, which when
you're a beautiful woman, you probably
wouldn't want to do that normally, but
it looks like she's attending a funeral.
There's a reason she's wearing this
strange hat with that large ring around
it that looks like
Saturn. And he's saying our vision is
one of peace, security, and prosperity.
So here we're talking about the peace
aspect, the the uh abundance of wealth
and all these things, right? The golden
age.
and his right-hand man is Elon Musk who
wants to microchip your brain with
Neurolink. And
then Trump had those guys come up, those
three guys that were spending 500
billion with a B dollars on AI
technology to roll out Stargate, which
is total surveillance of humanity
governed by artificial intelligence. And
so this is this is the system right
here. This is the plan is rolling out
the agenda. So just remember this golden
age
um making Trump a god raising to godhood
Saturn which was reigning over the
golden age peace prosperity security uh
merging man with
machine and total
dystopian what's what's going to be
promoted as a utopia because the guy who
owned Stargate said oh people are going
to behave it's going to be
But it's a dystopian world and this is
the age of Aquarius. So to break this
down even deeper, we got the golden
age. This is not some Christian term.
This is not some good term. This goes
back to the New Age movement. This is
this is what I'm getting at is people
think of Trump as being some Christian
and oh, he's just he's just using this
terminology because he's going to bring
in a a good era. No, the golden age has
really been predicted for a long time
that this is going to be a shift in
humanity bringing into the age of
Aquarius. Um, here's the Trump's
inauguration and how the ceiling, this
is an official website and it says that
there's a last minute change of plan
that they actually did it in the
building here and right under this
apotheiois of
Washington. And you see right here
there's Washington with the as above so
below hand gestures going on. And it
literally tells you in the central group
of the fresco. Did I underline anything
here? Yeah. The word
apotheiois in the title means literally
the raising of a person to a rank of god
of a god or the glorification of a
person as an ideal. So this is on the
official website like this is what they
say that they literally deified George
Washington and now they're doing the
same thing with
Trump. Uh so we go a little deeper on
this thing about the esoteric
traditions.
Uh in esoteric tradition, Saturn is
intrins
intricately connected to the concept of
the golden age, a mythical era
characterized by peace, prosperity, and
and harmony. This association manifest
in several key aspects. Saturn as the
ruler of the golden age. In Roman
mythology, Saturn is known as the god of
agriculture, wealth, and and time. Was
believed to have presided over a
primordial golden age. During his reign,
humanity experienced abundance and lived
in abundance with natural laws,
eliminating the need for external
governance. In Greek mythology, the
Greeks identified Saturn with Kronos,
the Titan who ruled during the Golden
Age. This period was marked by a utopian
existence free from toil and
suffering. And so here she is wearing
that hat that looks just like Saturn.
And this is not some reach. They even
know it's Saturn when these Catholic
priests wear it. It's called a Capello
or Capello Roman. It says a Capello
Roman Italian Roman hat or Satno.
So, I'm not just saying, "Oh, yeah, it
looks like Saturn or whatever." I'm not
trying to spin anything to my narrative.
I'm seeing it right in front of my very
eyes. Um, I pray to God for discernment,
and this is the kind of stuff that just
jumps out at me now. But the golden age
is the same as Aquarius and the ringed
planet Saturn. So you see at the top
this is the Theosophical Society and
this was written uh back in 2005 but the
idea goes way
back and it says right here in the 21st
century Saturn's influence and lessons
help us recover at least parts of the
golden consciousness that leads to the
golden society in our in our present
cycle. So they're this is what these
elitists want. It means the awakening of
the sixth intuitive subprinciple within
the fifth mental principle or simply the
rebirth of a spiritual intelligence a
higher level of consciousness from which
the next civilizations must embrace or
wait
emanate. So notice it's talking about
this rebirth. We keep showing on this
show that they are obsessed with this
idea of well the oraoris, the phoenix
rising out of the ashes. All this stuff
is esoteric symbology of this um rebirth
says it is a natural process now to
rediscover the bright side of Saturn. It
is an appropriate time to remember that
the ringed planet was for many centuries
the astrolog
astrological regent of Aquarius before
Uranus was discovered in 1781. Being
co-regent of the Aquarian age, Saturn
will have an ever inspiring role during
this new cycle. a time when the law of
brotherhood taught by the
motamus can be better understood and
respected. And then you got Elon Musk
who hopes to implant millions of
neurochip neurolink chips in people's
brains over the next decade. This is
like this is the type of stuff that the
the right the Republicans didn't want.
They thought we were getting away from
this stuff. And yet, for some reason,
when Elon Musk comes out with a chainsaw
at Trump's rallies, everybody's like,
"Yeah, this dude's awesome. Microchip my
brain."
Woo. Um, let's see what this is about
here. President Trump's first full day
back in office included a major
announcement about artificial
intelligence that'll bring jobs to
Texas. The president stood next to the
CEOs of OpenAI, Oracle, and Soft Bank to
announce a $500 billion project called
Stargate. The project would build new
data centers and electricity generation
needed to power AI.
I mean, dude, you can chime in,
bro. I was just wanting to get the flow
because, you know, the chart is pretty
vague, but I wanted to break down like
I'm not just making stuff up here.
Yeah. No, this is a good presentation
you put together here, Mikey. I really
enjoy this. Jordan Maxwell would uh be
proud. Very good. I don't know who that
is. Jordan Maxwell. Who's that? You
don't? Oh, okay. Oh, man. Like, well, he
Jordan Maxwell is a guy who was around
for a long time. And he he I he inspired
me to look into a cult and esoteric
concepts myself, but he was a researcher
into it for decades and decades. He's
doing it forever. He was doing it like
back in the 60s. He's talking about the
Illuminati and all that and Saturn was
something that he would go back to again
and again. So, he he was a good guy. He
um he died a couple of years back, but
uh
his material was great. He's a bit of a
divisive figure in the alternative
world, but I I thought he was great.
But, uh when when did you really like
I'm sure all of us were like
NPCs at one time.
uh nonplayable yeah NPCs and but then we
had a an awakening like whoa wait a
minute like there's actually something
going on I need to pay attention to like
when when was that for you?
Uh well I mean all my life I always felt
like something was off and just this
like what the hell are we even doing?
Like just looking around when you go
around public and like why why is it
like this? So I was always a little bit
like that. But then I think really when
911 happened, I was in college. I
actually watched on TV in my video class
because I was going for art and for
video and animation and stuff. I was um
I watched live the towers falling in my
video class. And so uh from that moment
on like um it took a couple years before
I still started looking into 911 truth.
That was probably about
2005 or so I really got into that and
from there it just kind of that was when
I really got into all this stuff big
time was about that time. Yeah. If if
you still believe 911 was you still
believe the official story about 911 or
the moon landing like you're never going
to see the stuff we're talking about.
Like those things are Pandora's box.
Like once you once those are you can see
that then you can see stuff. But if
you're still holding on to that, like
you're never going to see this stuff. My
dad actually, he's in here. He's Robert
Goule in the chat. What's up, dad? But
uh I've always been just like shock
rocker Marilyn Manson. Uh so my my
parents raised me in a Christian home. I
accepted it as a kid, but by 12, I was
just like, "Yeah, the church is never
minded and ignorant." And the the truth
is out there. I've always been a truth
seeker, open-minded, truth-seeking
skeptic. That's like the three things
I've always been. Always intrigued by
the paranormal, all that stuff. Never
been an atheist, always an agnostic.
Um, but I started going down the occult
world and
just depressed, hopeless, what is this
life for? What's going to happen at the
end of this thing? And escaping all the
time just through drugs and alcohol and
everything. And so I lived like a
mindless zombie for a long time. But I
knew that your vote didn't matter. I I
was so disconnected from politics. I
remember when it got brought up, I was
just like, "Time to walk away." Like,
and even though I had no clue of the
bigger scale of it, I knew that nothing
ever changed. I was like, "Look, you're
saying you vote Republican because
you're against abortion, but abortion's
always been legal, so what's really
changing?" And so I I never even had any
desire to vote. My dad actually bought
one of my votes one time and I was like,
"Sure, I'll take 30 bucks to vote for
Bush, you know, and that was when my dad
was still sleeping, but he actually in
2008, he was he was a truck driver at
night times and he was listening to
Coast to Coast AM. You know that one?"
Oh, yeah. Yeah. George Bell. Yeah. Art
Bell and George Nor. You know that. So,
he was hearing a lot of this stuff and
uh one day he watched Loose Change.
You're familiar with that, right? Oh,
yes. Yeah, I know that. So, the
documentary, I don't know when it
actually came out, but this was 2008, I
think. He was kind of just like going
down the rabbit hole a little bit. And
he said, "Mikey, I know you don't you
hate politics. You don't believe in any
of this conspiracy theory stuff?" Cuz I
I just I was brainwashed by movies and
everything that made conspiracy
theorists look crazy. And so, I just
thought, you know, thinking that there's
a big grand conspiracy is dumb. But I
was like, "Sure, I'll watch it with you.
Watch this documentary." And I by the
end of it, I was just like, "Wow, I I
can't reject anything I saw in that." I
totally believe that this was an inside
job, but in my mind, it was like one
event. It was like this isolated event.
Okay. Uh we we attacked ourselves to go
to go to war for oil or something, you
know, like I I was just so like isolated
in my mindset about it. And it wasn't
until December 2011, 28, 9, 10, 11. So
yeah, like probably three years later
that the scales really just fell off my
eyes. The blinders fell off and I was
just like, whoa. But my dad really
planted that seed. And then I started
noticing other things like I was just my
car was uh overheating and I was in this
parking lot waiting for it to cool down
and I was just watching these jets fly
over and I was just looking at these
long trails going all the way across the
sky. And as I was sitting there for a
while they just kept getting bigger and
bigger and I was
like are those things coming down or
what what is going on? Like to me it it
was like a a total divine appointment to
be like abandoned in that parking lot
with no trees, no buildings, no nothing.
Just a huge field and I'm just for some
reason my attention is on these trails
and
I'm I I'm actually paying attention like
why are they getting bigger? Like fog is
supposed to go away. Condensation goes
away. It doesn't grow. And it it
impressed me so much that later that day
when I saw my dad, I was like, "Yeah, I
was watching these trails and they
looked like they were falling down or
getting bigger or something." And he
said, "Yeah, they call them chemtrails."
I hate to say the word cuz it's going to
be flagged now, but I was like, "What?"
And he heard about it from listening to
the radio uh coast to coast and stuff.
And I was like, I can't believe I'm like
having a a g like a legit conversation
with my dad
about secret military project spraying
humanity with chemicals and stuff like
and then it was real shortly after that
that the blinders just fell off
completely and I was like whoa like
there is a whole system being set up
behind the scenes there. We are being
distracted by American idols and
entertainment and video games and oh
yeah just on this hamster wheel of the
um industrial revolution and all this
stuff like we're already slaves. You
just get to choose your slave master. Is
it going to be McDonald's or is it going
to be the hospital or whatever? But
you're going to work and you're going to
pay taxes on your house that you own and
all this stuff. And it's all a
distraction to and we're like we're
building our own demise because your
taxes is coming out of the check that
you're making and it's going
towards whatever. You have no idea what
it's going towards. Um weaponization and
all
that. And yeah, that's kind of what
happened to me. Like 2008 was like a
seed planted, but I couldn't see the big
picture
until other things
happen. And yeah, I can never see the
world again the same way
again. Yeah. Yeah. No, that's that's the
way it goes for so many. And yeah, it's
uh good memories for me to kind of look
back and think about uh the early days
of running into this stuff and um so
much you learn along the
way. And I, as I said before, in 2008, I
put the age of transitions video, that
hourlong video onto Google video. At the
time, there was Google video, which
Google ended up buying YouTube
uh couple years after. It was it was
Google video and YouTube eventually
merged essentially, but I put it on
there and Yeah. Yeah. Google video was a
weird platform. There were a lot of it
was used for mainly like um longer form
videos. So mine was an hour long. You
would see like sometimes it'd be 20
minutes but usually longer than that. Uh
there'd be like episodes of like strange
maybe documentary TV shows and stuff
that people would put on there
sometimes. But uh yeah, back in the day
YouTube wouldn't let you have a video
longer than 10 minutes or something like
that. I forgot about that. Google video
was the place to go if you had like a
long thing and you put it on there. And
so I just kind of loaded it. I'm like,
"Ah, okay." I I figured I just let the
video be whatever it is. I'd let it live
online. But I actually got
um radio show and podcast invites from
it. People started watching it. Got a
lot of views actually. And so people
started inviting me on shows and then so
I sort of was entered into this world
from that. I just kind of went with it.
I'm like, "Oh, okay." And then there's
my own. And so I've been doing this for
a long time. So, I have the I
think so many people come and go in
this. Did Alex Jones ever reach out to
you, man?
Uh, I called in to the Alex Jones show
early on in my career of this and uh he
he played one of my shorter videos about
transhumanism and then I called in,
"Hey, I'm the guy that made the video."
And he was like, "Oh, okay." Blah, blah,
blah. And that was about it. Yeah. Um I
I used to listen to Alex Jones all the
time. Yeah, me too. 2006. 2006 to 2010,
maybe. And wow, that was way earlier.
For me, it was 2012 was a big time for
me. Dude, I thought you were younger
than me, man. No, I'm You got youth on
your side, bro. Uh, no. I've I've been
around for a while and I there's there's
just a lot to learn and I feel lucky in
that I've been on the inside so I've
known like what people who make this
sort of media a little bit of behind the
scenes. I mean, I'm not
always sometimes and and I was telling
you before the show started, Mikey, that
I'm not much of people aren't too
friendly with me these days and not I
don't get many invites to too many shows
because I don't tow the party line. And
if you don't think that there is a party
line when it comes to this stuff, I'm
sorry that you don't notice, but there
absolutely is. And it's a absolute
travesty
that uh something that was once called
the truth movement has devolved into
this
uh absolute disgrace.
It's just a bunch of propaganda is what
it's it's it's it's a new form of
propaganda. Guys like Elon Musk have
bought the distribution channels for it.
Yep. X and and Yeah. Yeah. That's all
that thing is. X is an online
propaganda distribution channel. Full
stop. Okay. Now, I'm on it and I use it
and I attempt to promote my stuff. I
don't get very far with it. Yeah. But
that's that's what's going on there. And
it's and this is where, as I told you, I
get worked up about this stuff because I
have been around and I I can see what's
going on now. And I've I'm sick of it. I
I don't want to see people fooled any
longer and and and misdirected. The
misdirection
and there's a lot of stuff that people
don't want to admit is
true and it's called out as like, oh,
there's certain taboo topics that
immediately will get shot right down.
Like if you try to insinuate that
there's such a thing as foreign
propaganda influence on us, uh,
specifically Russian, if if if you start
talking about, oh, yeah, Russian
propaganda. Oh, you're just a you're a
dumb liberal or something like that. As
if there is no such thing as Russian
propaganda. There is. That's crazy. All
right. There's Russian propaganda.
There's propaganda. It's all sorts of
it. I'll say it's hard for me to accept
some of that in a sense. Not for the
reason you're talking about, but in the
sense that I think the whole world is in
on it. So it's like I don't think
China's the enemy or Russia's the enemy.
It's like it's United Nations. They all
get together and have meetings like,
"All right, so who's going to go to war
with who?"
And but yeah, I mean, Tik Tok is owned
by Chinese and they're they're supposed
to be gathering information and all this
stuff. I remember did you know about Ace
of Bass? band who was uh well they
they're they're German, aren't they?
Aren't they a German band? Asa base?
Yeah. The guy that started it was like a
Nazi neo-Nazi or something. That was
always a rumor. I think even in the '9s
when they had their big uh run that
people would say that they're Nazis. I
don't know the facts behind that. I've
seen a photograph of him like with the
swats and everything. Yeah. Yeah. It's
hard to believe. Okay.
Yeah. Yeah. I
mean, I that to me uh in the '9s there
there's a whole wave of those European
bands for some reason. There were a lot
of them that were uh a lot of them from
Germany or somewhere from Europe. They'd
have that Yeah, that Europ technoey kind
of electronic very poppy stuff. But
yeah, that's uh it's pop culture stuff.
But uh um so I mean is this synopsis of
your book like accurate? I mean was
there anything I was reading that you're
like wait I never said that or uh I I
found it interesting what the AI chose
to focus on. Um all that stuff I'm sure
is in there.
uh it it focused in on the Saturn
element, which is an interesting thing
to do when you're talking about the
golden age. And if you want to tie it to
the myths of
Saturn, is a fascinating
uh god amongst the uh you know, the
pantheon of classical civilization.
There's a lot going on with the idea of
the golden age specifically with Saturn
and they said um in that in the synopsis
it brought up how there's the connection
to Kronos and time and I think there's
all sorts of ways to break this down and
some of them are highly esoteric and
even metaphysical. M I think there's an
aspect of Saturn where Saturn has a lot
to do with actual time
itself. Time and
motion and I think sound works its way
into this too. And actually the concept
of the golden age I
believe the sort of like meditative
thing that you're supposed to derive out
of this
is a golden age that existed before time
even was a thing before there is no
death or old the age there's no death in
the uh golden age of Saturn right yeah
right so I I think this is just meant
for you
to
imagine a space where there is no time
there is no death there is no sound
there's no motion nothing's moving
everything's completely
still And this this this is where it
gets quite esoteric and and and
metaphysical. So that's that aspect of
it. But there's also if you're talking
about the ages, like concepts of ages,
if we're talking about a golden age,
this is where we're looking to the
past, there's different ways to to look.
Which which way do we point our gaze? Do
we look to the past to the past golden
age in which we have lost and we have
devolved over time? There's an idea that
um there's been these sequence of ages
since the golden age and we they each
one is like a metal that has devolved
further and further. The golden people
created the iron people. I was reading
that in your book actually. Mhm. Mhm.
Eventually you get to iron. So that's
highly alchemical. So it's that's taking
the high ideal of
gold and degrading it over time. So it's
the idea of deevolution. And this would
kind of tie into the Gnostic concept
that we have devolved from the spiritual
creatures that we truly are. No death,
no uh truly only spiritual. That's like
a spiritual spot if we're talking about
that Saturnian golden age, right? We
have fallen from that. We have fallen
into this physical world and we have
progressively devolved.
Now there's another direction to look
which is towards the future and this is
the esqueologgical view where we the
golden age is something for us to
attain for the freemasons again the
great work of the ages how do we reach
our apotheiois
which can be done individually as it was
with George Washington in your example
there that's interesting freemasonic
concept of the apotheiois there's a lot
to get into there But I believe that the
high esoteric goal of apotheiois of
golden age of the great work is has
always been collective as collective
human
race. And so what it is is how do we
unite and
become what we truly are meant to be
right in the macrocosmic sense. And if
you want to get religious and
metaphysical again, it would be
uniting with God or depending on who you
are creating God. Yeah. And there's a
whole and if you want to talk Luciferian
Prometheian, maybe that's where you go
direction there where it's not about us
necessarily merging with God and all
that, but rather creating a god and
hoping that it decides that it merges
with us or whatever, right? Like what?
And this plays with all sorts of ideas
with the creation with creation and the
creator. Uh who made who AC/DC, right?
The song like who made who? Who turned
the screw. I love that song. It's
actually to me that's a profound song,
right? You wouldn't think so, but uh
it's it was um made famous from Oh, what
was that Stephen King movie? Uh
oh, it was a terrible It was the only
movie that Stephen
It was the only movie that he ever
directed. It was based on one of his
books, Maximum Overdrive. Oh, it's
horrible. Oh. Oh. Oh. Was that the one
with the gremlins on the semir or
something? Yes. Yes, that's the one.
Yeah. Yeah. Oh, wow. It's it's a damn
shame because the movie the concepts in
the movie and that AC/DC song to me it's
profound and it's like speaking about
all these like
high esoteric concepts but then the
movie is a total dud. It's like to me
that was like one of the great
travesties of cinema there. It's like
man what could have been? Wow.
And Stephen King said well I was high on
cocaine so sorry. Is that what he said?
Well, he basically said that. I want to
uh change a scene here. I wanted to make
sure you weren't talking or something
when I mess around with it because I'm
I'm trying to get us both to see
Chrome.
Uh, okay. I'm going to have to put us in
here real quick. I can edit this out
later. Uh,
uh, let me see. I hope I can do this
right. Me. Yeah. And
you. Perfect. All right. So, have you
you seen this before?
Not before tonight when you mentioned
it. I looked it up. Yeah. So, this is
something that people were were pointing
out. There's a a magazine called The
Economist. I honestly don't know much
about it. My wife said it's some
esoteric magazine. I don't know if it
comes out like once a year or what, but
this was on the cover and it came out
like the beginning of the year and
Trump's dead center. He wasn't the
president yet, which is interesting. We
do see the one eye symbolism on here a
couple times. We see this little thing
right there that you're not allowed to
talk about on
YouTube. Um, the stock market's going
up. Isn't that interesting?
because I do believe that we're going to
enter into a manufactured
uh utopia. Like, dude, I I believe the
the Great Depression and all that stuff
was
manufactured. So, yeah, gas prices are
going to get cheaper, food's going to
get cheaper. We're all going to be happy
for for a time. I mean, we're going to
think this is great and it's going to
let our guard
down and you know, their agenda is still
going is still going. I mean, you see
time is running out
here. Um, and
Saturn right
here. I'm not sure what the city is. I I
think people have said something about
it being smart
cities, but I don't I don't know how to
prove that. Smart Smart Cities. Smart
cities is a fascinating topic too. You
know, nuclear war coming. I have heard
people say that they really think that
that's going to be a threat lately. And
dude, from a from a Christian Bible
believing prophetic standpoint, I do
believe that they're it's order out of
chaos. They're going, they have to
create something so terrifying that the
whole world will submit ultimately to
Satan, who's a
spiritual, a supernatural being who's
going to manifest in this world and
pretend to be Christ.
And it's going to come at just the right
time after all these quote unquote
natural disasters, after, you know, the
world's just been in utter chaos and
there's nuclear war coming and all that
stuff. And I I've been predicting that
this whole growth that the you know the
gas is better and the golden age that's
coming the utopia that's coming all of
that is going to be kind of like setting
up Trump as some as a as a as a pawn as
a decoy
antichrist
basically that Satan will come as a
supernatural being and overthrow
Trump because biblically I don't know
how much you know about it but
biblically
Christians are looking for an antichrist
first. That's that's the way this plays
out. Like the world gets really bad, an
antichrist comes on the scene and he's
promising peace and safety and like a
utopia and all that stuff and it's he's
going to form a one world order, a one
world religion where it's all kind of
like, hey, we all have the same God.
Let's just get along and it's going to
look
great. And and but the Bible says when
he says peace and safety, sudden
destruction comes. So when that time of
peace and safety comes, then we can
expect Christ's return and all the
wickedness in this world will be
cleansed and we will live in a true
perfect world for
eternity. So in order for Satan, who's a
master deceiver, in order for him to
come as Christ and actually fool the
Christians, he has to set up an
antichrist first to overthrow. And so I
feel like, you know, the Antichrist is
supposed to be this um charismatic
person that's actually doing all these
great things. And so I think he's the
man. Don't get me twisted. I don't think
he's literally the Antichrist. I think
he's a pawn in the whole game, the whole
chess game that's going on. He's
bringing about a better economy,
uh but he's also setting up this utopia
at the same time. And that's when people
are going to be like, "Wait a minute. We
thought this guy was good, but he's
setting up a utop he's setting up this
dystopian
world. We fell for the Antichrist. He's
the Antichrist. I think people are going
to end up turning on this guy
eventually.
You know what's interesting is he's
talking about golden age. Yeah. Which is
very much if you're talking about ages,
this is eons. This is like thousands of
year time spans we're talking about,
right? Huge time spans. And this guy
who, you know, his golden age is just
about making a buck today. Yeah. Right.
So his golden age is, oh yeah, we're
going to make a bunch of money cuz
China's been screwing us over and we're
going to figure out with the tariffs how
to get back at it.
So, it's it's interesting to see
like and how interestingly American this
is about like just thinking only in the
immediate and of the immediate gain, but
labeling it something way beyond what it
deserves. We're talking about a golden
This is not a golden age. This is a
presidential administration. You got to
be kidding me. You know what I mean? and
he's not bringing in any like time
that's going to last for thousands of
years. Yeah. Right. So, that's one
aspect to look at this for one thing. Um
but yeah, that's the the concept of some
sort
of new form of entity that if you if you
want to call it uh dark spiritual entity
that could incarnate into something like
an AGI. That's a fascinating concept
that we don't know. I mean, it's it's
it's within the realm of possibility.
Now, if AGI is something that actually
happens, I mean, what does that mean?
That this new form of consciousness goes
into a machine. So, there's a lot going
on with that. Here's the prediction
right here. And we got the space travel
stuff going on, but here's the
prediction. The the uprising is coming.
everybody's gonna go turn on him and
that's when Satan can appear as as the
Christ and and really deceive the entire
world. It says that the dragon will
deceive the entire world through lying
signs and wonders and and uh these are
going to be miracle working demons which
I believe will appear as
extraterrestrial. Um I believe
that what what's coming is going to make
every religion on earth request
everything. I mean, Jesus coming out of
a UFO or whatever and and all this
ancient alien stuff that's out there
like, oh yeah, you know, Moses was led
out of the wilderness by a beam of light
from a UFO and a pillar of smoke that
was the exhaust of a UFO and Ezekiel saw
a wheel within a wheel UFO. So, it's
such a perfect
deception. Jesus steps out of UFO and
the Christians are going to be like,
"Okay, well, we didn't realize that he
traveled in a UFO, but okay." And then
the newagers are going to be like,
"Well, we knew he was in a UFO. Jesus is
a one of the ascended masters like all
the rest." And uh it's just going to
cause everyone to really question
everything because we are such see it to
believe it creatures. And I I get it. I
mean, I I have that mentality, too. I
came to Christ because I did see things
not not apparitions or anything, but I
saw my prayers be answered in ways that
I just could no longer keep uh
rejecting. I couldn't I couldn't I could
no longer keep ignoring that God was
answering my prayers in very specific
ways. And um and that's continued since
2005. So, I mean, 20 years of of this
and it's just
getting stronger and more intense. Like,
when I see Bible prophecy is actually
coming true and everything, it's like I
I can't unsee what I see now. But, um,
yeah, this is
really, so I I don't believe we can like
put our trust in
like esoteric writers or whatever, but I
do believe that these people have a
plan. This is their game plan. This
isn't like somebody that can tell the
future. They just know the playbook like
the the guy who made the Illuminati card
game. You looked into that stuff. I I've
I've seen images of it over Yeah. I've
seen it time and again, but I I don't
know a lot of the history of the
creation of it, though. Right. No, I
don't know if many people do, but it's
kind of theorized that he was some
insider that wanted to get the truth out
there. So he put in a card game and it's
very interesting from 9/11 to the
Pentagon to ducks in a oil spill, BP oil
spill to even the alien and flat earth
and all that stuff is is in there. And
uh this is really my first time looking
at this. I've seen this image get passed
around a lot, but I didn't really get to
analyze all of it. What do you know what
this is? Is this like a the woman down
there? I'm not sure who that is. It's uh
obviously like old time someone from the
past. Yeah, it's an illustration from I
don't know what era or who that is. I
would like to know.
Wow, dude. So, yeah, I wanted to get
this on screen because it wasn't in my
presentation, but in the
presentation, I don't know why that is
lagging so much.
Uh, okay. So, here he's literally
talking about this surveillance state,
the rise of a modern surveillance state
where citizens will be on their best
behavior. Sounds like a place I want to
live. Um, here's a here's a speech where
Trump is saying this. We have before us
a rare
opportunity to bring security and
stability and peace to this region and
to its people. So he said peace and
security which the Bible in 1
Thessalonians 5:3 says for when they
shall say this is talking about the end
times it says uh for when they shall say
peace and safety then sudden destruction
cometh upon them as travail upon a woman
with child and they shall not escape. So
it's a a prediction about when Christ
returns. It's a describing the scene of
what it's going to be like. uh there's
going to be a lot of chaos and
tribulation and all that, but
then a um a power is going to come on
the scene that is promising peace and
safety. I just think it's interesting
that he's promising peace and safety.
[Music]
Um he's he's doing all these things
literally. He's he's fulfilling all
these strange markers of the Antichrist.
And so I don't believe I'm not one of
those that are like, "Oh, Trump's the
Antichrist." I believe
that's the plan to make us believe he's
the Antichrist so that we will fall for
the true
Antichrist. And uh I don't know how you
would feel about that, but
um this Whoops, wrong one. This right
here is the breakdown. So we just went
through all of it piece by piece.
And we see Saturn's role. I I believe
that that hat that she's wearing is not
just some fashion choice. I don't think
that at all. I don't I think that was
purposeful. Um he's talking about the
golden age. Saturn is going to rule.
It's a time of peace coming. Peace and
safety. These these people are a
cultist. They are following whether you
believe the Bible or whether you believe
in Satan or whatever these people do.
That's the scary part. They do. And so
this occult group is often they see it
as an age of a time to return to and we
need to achieve it through secret
knowledge and merging man with machine.
That's the brain chip and activating
hidden divine. Oh man. Hidden divine
potential. And the elites are reviving
the sat Saturn Saturn Saturnian
worship. And it's a guise of a utopian
scientific future and it's a a veiled
system of control or
destruction. So are are you seeing the
stuff I'm seeing, man?
Yes. Yeah. I mean, again, you you have
the
Christian belief take on it, which I
completely understand because if we're
talking about uh making conscious
machines Mhm. what are we to make of
that? I mean, and then that just plays
into
the god complex of these guys like Ray
Carter when he says like um at the end
of his autobiographical documentary
thing somebody asked him if he believes
in God he says uh we haven't made it
yet. Wow. Who who was that? Like who who
is he? Was he that was Ray? That was
Ray. Oh Ray Curtzwell. He um he's the
big guy that made the term singularity
popular. He's one that has really he's
one of the big um faces of transhumanist
concepts. If you know about
transhumanism, it's a lot to do with him
and his life's work is really as a PR
person for this. Uh he's got some cushy
job at Google now. Um, but he's written
a lot of books about the singularity
um, AI and AGI, how it's inevitable and
all that. So that's Curtzwell, but
um, yeah, there's just, uh, the AGI
thing, honestly, I go back and forth
with it. I know some people are like
really all in like, "Yeah, it's going to
come. That's what So, and and you're
either like, yeah, that's what we need
to save us from everything." Or you
think, "Yeah, that's just going to
destroy us all." Yeah. Right. To me,
I've kind of um I'm wondering
if AGI, actual conscious intelligent
machines are a smoke screen used. I'm
sure it has been used this way, but it's
just an extent to how much it's been
used this way that we're meant to talk
about that. So we never do talk about
the more boring narrow AI systems which
absolutely are everywhere now being used
to control our lives being infused into
the government by Doge, right? That
whole Doge thing. Everybody's up in arms
about that. The big uh the big thing
about that is Musk is going in there and
uh integrating all these AI systems into
the fabric of the United States
government.
So all of the information on every US
citizen is being fed into this AI
command and control system that they're
now setting up. So that's not a machine
that can think and that can uh act and
that is conscious or anything in any
way, but it's something that is a tool
that can be used by these guys that want
to control us in every aspect of our
life. Yeah. So, I kind of I I've taken
it recently that I'm defaulting to the
narrow AI is
more it's what we probably should be
looking at right now. But be that as it
may, I don't know. The AGI thing could
just end up happening at some point and
that's a whole another crazy thing. So,
it's kind of like how they got us all
scared of terminators, machines that are
going to kill us and stuff, but it's
like, no, it's actually
like way
more subtle than that.
Yeah, it's subtle. It's mundane. It's a
little boring. It's nerdy, but it's also
horrifying. It can be used uh
effectively to uh gain a lot of control
over a lot of things. and and and once
again the whole
um the online propaganda global
propaganda matrix is something that we
have to be more careful in quite frankly
because too many people are just taking
for granted all of this stuff that just
is like oh here's another meme and um
yeah here's the here's the latest truth
that we just uncovered. It's like who
uncovered it and and
Am I seeing like 10 different people
carbon copies saying the same thing? Is
this a talking point? This a new point
of truth that you're trying to convince
me of? And if so, who are they? What's
their agenda? There's so many
agendas. There's a lot of people clearly
trying to get us to believe a lot of
things. I don't want to believe any of
it. Yeah, I want to actually continue to
try to like figure out what's truly
going on, be fooled less often because I
know I'm going to be fooled. We all will
be, but I want to be fooled less
often. And I just want to know what's
actually happening to the best of my
ability. And it's it's getting it's
getting difficult to do that. Yeah, it
is. Oh, man. It's getting hard to even
tell the difference in AI images and
videos and stuff anymore. I mean, I use
it so much that I kind of it kind of
stands out to me because I notice like
the overcontrasted
uh colors and the things that have like
extra smoothness or shine or whatever.
But I mean, honestly, some of the
pictures that I saw of these chicks that
went up to space or whatever, they
looked AI and I was like, is it what?
Like, now I'm starting to question real
stuff, which I don't honestly don't even
believe a lot of these people are even
going to space or anything. But, but
besides that, the photographs of the
women, I'm like I can't even I'm like
starting to question reality now. Like,
is that AI? Um, I po I posted a video of
in Germany the whole crowd were holding
poster boards black and red and they
were flipping the poster boards over and
it made a giant red pentagram and then
they rose a banner of Satan up and there
were cards that lifted that flipped in
Latin it was saying um, Lucifer take our
souls and all this stuff and there were
people swearing like this is AI and I'm
like it's not AI. I I know for a fact
that's not AI because I've looked at
different angles, different footage. The
the spelling is correct. There's no
glitches. There's no weird morphing or
anything. It's the footage is longer
than AI can create. It's a handheld
camera. All that kind of stuff is why I
know it's real. But again, people are
starting to think, "Oh, that's AI." when
it's
reality and where AI is right now is the
worst it's ever going to be.
It's evolving every moment of every day.
And so, yeah, we laughed at Will Smith
like shoving spaghetti in his mouth and
people having like eight fingers and
stuff, but now it's only been two years
since that or something. And we're like,
is that is that AI? Is that real? I
can't tell.
I mean, dude, it's it's going to get
crazy, man. It's going fast. Yeah. Don't
don't take that for granted. It's going
faster all the time. Things are going to
get crazy.
Uh yeah, there's just um
honestly it's about
keeping your wits about you really
because as you said, it's so easy to
question
yourself. You can second guess
everything. Now is a time where you
really have to double down on what it is
that you do know what it is that you
feel is your purpose and what you're
trying to
do.
And yes,
discernment. We need better discernment
in being able
to see
through liars, honestly, because there's
so many of them.
And I don't want to stand up here and
act like I I see every lie that's in
front of me. Um that that I I know the
full truth and I have it. But I will say
that over
time once again like with my experience
in this strange ecosystem, this
conspiracy culture alternative world
that's continues to be maligned, always
has been maligned, still is even when
people should not be. People should be
trying to understand it so that they can
understand what's actually going on.
Yeah. But no, that won't happen. Stop
burying their head in the sand, you
know. Yeah. Yeah. It's it's just
um there there's so many directions to
go with this because I I I I get very
upset at people who believe that they're
better. It's like, "Oh, I'm I'm better
than those stupid conspiracy nuts. I
wouldn't believe that stuff." And it's
like and then just
like I I don't know. I I don't I
honestly don't even know what direction
to go in
because it's just so frustrating to see
everybody being fooled by all of this
and so many people not even
understanding the name of the game.
Yeah.
Um there's a but there's a lot going on
and just so I would say have an open
mind but also you know be steadfast on
what you know is important. Mhm. But be
willing to uh
accept good new information when it
comes comes about and and and and the
discernment of uh
learning the
multitudes of deceivers that are all
over all over the place. Wow. Just want
there. I mean, I that that honestly
that's what I've gotten over time the
most out of this is just seeing seeing
how quickly somebody goes from like, you
know, I'm I got a bullhorn in the street
yelling about 9/11's an inside job to
now they're just a propaganda mouthpiece
for the new truth, which is anything
but. It just isn't. Wow, man. That was
like the perfect wrap-up for the show. I
hope I have this uh loaded where I can
show
uh Is it going to pop up? I don't know
why it's
lagging. Yes. So, if you guys were
interested in this show, man. Aaron,
thank you so much for coming on. You
guys don't even know like how this all
happened. I ran across this video in
2012 and bought it. Read the I didn't
read the book, but I have the book and I
have read parts of it. I won't lie and
say I read the whole thing, but u the
documentary is amazing and it stuck with
me all this time to where when I started
seeing these things play out, I was
like, "Wait a minute, that's just like
what that dude was saying in that
documentary." And I reached out to him
yesterday and invited him on the show
today and he was willing to come on. So
Aaron, thank you so much for this
awesome discussion. And if you guys want
to check out his website, it is the age
of
transitions.com. His video is available
on here and he's got a podcast and he's
got this book. I don't know if you have
other books, but you have definitely
um saw things that were coming before a
lot of other people did. And so I
appreciate your work, man.
Well, I appreciate you having me on,
Mikey. I I thank you a lot, man. And I I
know that you're somebody that's doing
things for the right reasons. And as is,
as as I was alluding to earlier, there's
so many that aren't. I know that you
are, man. That means that means the
world. It really does. So, uh, thank you
so much for having me. Yeah. Thank you
so much, man. We'll stick around and
I'll sign off here.
Thank you guys for being here for this
show. I hope it was eye openening. You
know, we cannot just trust the next
elected politician. Even if he's made to
look like the messiah, we have to look
around and see like what is really
happening behind the scenes. Yes, he's
getting rid of woke culture. Yes, gas
prices are going to get better and food
prices are going to get better. But
there's still an agenda rolling out. So,
don't fall asleep. Don't bury your head
in the sand. Stay awake. Stay vigilant
and pay attention. If you guys enjoyed
this, please click a thumbs up. It
really helps get this video out into the
algorithm so more people can see it.
Please click a uh subscribe if you're
new and share this video with your
family and friends. If you want to
support this channel, you can do so by
going to candidtruth.org. We depend on
you. We do this for uh full-time. We do
it for a living, my wife and I. And so
if you want to support us like some
others out there have, we thank you so
much. you can do so on these digital
platforms. We also have cool t-shirts.
Be cool, use your brain, the truth will
set you free, love is kind, and many
others on our uh website there if you
want to check those out. I'm actually
wearing one right now. This is the retro
brain design. This is Candid Truth. And
um don't forget, check out Aaron Fronn's
website, The Age of Transitions. Check
out the book. Check out the documentary
for sure. And we love you guys. We can't
do this without you. And we'll see you
next time on Candid Truth.